one of the biggest ones was game three
in 2001 when President Bush came out
throughout the first pitch through a
perfect strike and uh he actually came
in with his bulletproof vest in New York
we're playing the um the uh Arizona
Diamondbacks and we're down two nothing
and Mr Steinbrenner had brought back all
the all the police officers and
firefighters and people that lost their
loved ones I I it was it was probably
one of the the most emotional games I
had to pitch because when I busted out
of the locker room in old Yankee Stadium
I turn right and go about 20 yards to go
to the weight room to do my cuff work
and get loose I don't like running in
front of the fans and stuff I'll get on
a treadmill and get all my priests so
when I go out there I'm hot and here we
go
and I busted out of the clubhouse door
and like I had some men and women some
firemen just hugging me
[Music]
[Applause]